hey Leute und willkommen zu einer neuen
Adventure Map mit dem spark of Phoenix
und zwar haben wir uns gedacht ich
erkläre mal die komplette Situation die
damit griswal aufgetreten ist mit der
Map und zwar war das bei du darfst
übrigens erstmal Hallo sagen ne ja ja
ich bin da hallo ich ja also nicht dass
ihr denkt ich mach das alleine und nur
sein Skin ist hier so beweg dich mal ich
kann mich nicht gerade bewegen oh mein
Gott er kann laufen
das das musste natürlich wieder sein
okay ich komme mal zu der Situation mit
Professor griswal oder wie die Map hieß
wir haben schon eine Menge Parts
aufgenommen und das war immer so ein so
ein hechtelmächtel von ja da konnten wir
das nicht machen weil das die und die
Version war und da ging das und das
nicht und das war halt alles relativ BL
ne nee pass auf das war folgendes der
Server hat eine Einstellung gehabt wo
wir keinen Schaden bekommen haben noch
das sind Pfeile geflogen das ist wir
sind durch Lava geschwommen wir sind
gefallen alles mögliche kam halt nichts
ne kein Schaden und dann war es am Ende
noch so dass dann die Audiospur gefehlt
hat irgendwann bei einer Folge und dann
war alles to für ein Arsch und dann
haben wir uns schweren Herzen dazu
entschlossen Projekt nicht
weiterzuführen ganz einfach weil es
sinnlos wäre und deshalb machen wir
einfach ein neues Projekt ganz einfach
richtig da haben wir uns jetzt die Map
t3c rausgesucht die ich von weiß nicht
vor zwei Wochen oder so schon mal im
Blick hatte und selbst machen wollte
haben wir gesehen dass PE gemacht hat
und dann haben wir uns gedacht
komm natürlich als ob wir eigenen Style
haben na
ja wel
blaaace ja habe
ich
na ja go Break also die wollen jetzt
erstmal testen ob wir in der richtigen
Version sind ja das können wir sogar
cool ach so willst du vielleicht erstmal
die Regeln Vorlesen ach so ja ja aber
Sekunde Sekunde Sekunde habe ich
geöffnet in SK und zwar do not break
anything also nichts kaputt machen wir
sollen nichts bauen und einiges stages
oder einige Gebiete ih eigenen Regeln
und die musst du auch befolgen manchmal
kannst g reg stoßen kommt draf an wie
die instructions am Anfang dieses stage
sind so immer immer auf peacewall
spielen es sei denn es ist gewünscht
ähm verwire dich nicht mit dem
Schwierigkeitsgrad z.B
Schwierigkeitsgrad Stufe 2 heißt hart
das ist aber nicht sof hart spielen soll
sondern bleib ein peaceful Mode und wenn
nicht dann könnte ein Creeper halt
kommen als explodieren oder Enderman
können paar Sachen klauen so weiter und
so fort das würde die Map unspielbar
machen ähm springe nicht von einer
Challenge zu einer anderen das heißt von
Challenge 2 zu zu Challenge 1 weil das
wä dann cheaten und das Bett ist dafür
da um damit wir die Nacht überspringen
können wir sollen es auch nicht zum
cheaten nutzen nutz also nur für die
Nacht und Sprint Jump ist nicht eraubt
in 3 4 5 und 7 ja okay ich würde sagen
du lässt die mal nebenbei noch offen ne
weil damit wir das Behalten für 3 5 7
Blabla also das erste haben wir hier
geschafft und was ich relativ geil finde
man sieht ja hier die Tür da steht
sofort ja wenn du hier nicht hoch kannst
dann geh bitte hier durch die Tür ich
denke dass da dann komplett was anderes
hinter sein wird also dass die echt
gedacht haben komm anstatt dass die
zurückpatchen müssen machen wir das so
ja okay Walk side of the
fence okay ja das geht noch
dadurch okay richtig Design hier nur
informativ über die Map und Du darfst
ignoren ignorieren wenn du nicht lesen
willst ich würde sagen wir lesen nicht
Wirich ziemlich viele und da sich ja
viele schon beschwert haben
K oh wie süß bin
to so wo sind wir jetzt oh mein Gott wir
sind
draußen36 t3c heiß die m so Bo voll
cool wo bist du da
okay turn Multiplayer check the notepad
da waren wir play of
peacefule
wir dingst ja wir haben das gemacht you
spawed in Zone a challenge 1:8 Regeln
die haben wir uns alle schon
durchgelesen players guidelines the
challenges are not arranged oh mein Gott
ein gelbes Schaf was oh oh mein Gott
gefärbt first time h go do not play the
challenges that attack with you Redstone
Pistons time doors if you are running on
a slow Computer they cause lag Blabla
Regeln kennen wir schon das wäre wichtig
für michm ja ich habe hier gerade es
gupd auf 1.2.4 ich habe gerade bin gar
nicht vorbereitet und ich muss aufnehmen
wenn ich aufnehme bin ich bei 10 FPS
bring B skip the notat okay ich würde
sagen ich nehme mal zwei Betten
sicherheitsalf mit vielleicht weil ich
eins verliere und eine komplette
Rüstung eine eine Karte ne das ist n
Note oder kte od das ist eine Karte
wahrscheinlich von dieser kompletten map
ah cool guck jetzt mal an J klar das ist
das gleiche was was ich dir gerade per
bildschirmübertragung gezeigt hab okay
ja ich krieg sogar Livestream übertragen
von concrafter ja ja natürlich okay
exakt jetzt gleich nim mal du die Map
weil du gerade cameraman bist und ja
interessant so also wollen wir Moment
warte mal das haben das habe ich gerade
schon alles eingestellt was haben wir
hier drin oh interessant dann nehme ich
doch mal ein paar von mit ich würde
sagen ein Stck reicht die kannst du e
nicht alle essen und wenn wir sterbener
so dann haben wir noch wieder
neue natürlich gleich
F See ich eiskalt einer reicht die
kannst du gar nicht alle essen doch
schaffe ich Single Player commands Mod
Teleport Comm use go Comm Teleport
yourself blaa go C9 want go SP ne das
haben wir aber nicht weil wir in
multiplayer sind ADP stand for average
difficulty point wollen einfach anfangen
ja okay wir haben die sch alle gelesen
wir können starten warte mal turn
welcome so
hier wo wo haben wir denn a challenge 1
beginners playground hier sind irgendwie
viel zu viele Schilder viel zu viel
Information Schilderwald nennt man sowas
auch no of stages Sprint Jump ist allow
in Challenge okay lass erstmal hier
durchlaufen
TR Challenge BM warte hier ist jetzt dis
drin ich tu die mal hier rein Moment
warte mal wie macht man das denn so
glaube ich nee
so
ach ja
schön ach wie süß was eine schöne Musik
warte ich mach den Sound mal
leiser so dann lass mal hier drüber oder
ja den Check Gens öffnen dass wir
von draußen reinkommen können falls mir
einmal gefallen sind oder so nicht
wieder alles neu machen müssen ja genau
hier siehst du schon die nächsten
challenges also es ist auf jeden Fall
eine Menge challenges und ich glaub das
wird relativ einfach hust hust
so
ich glaube du schaffst das nicht oder
hast
geschafft boah geil ich habe sogar den
klacken gehört was haben wir jetzt ah
hier Checkpoint so Stage 1 Von D warte
ach so hier so Hop und Hop und Hop und
Hop ja jetzt beim nächsten musst du
aufpassen ja okay gut jetzt hier wieder
ein Checkpoint holen hier rüber so hier
hoch dann hier schräg und hier noch mal
schräg und hier noch mal schräg und H oh
mein Gott so
ich bin hier ich warte mal auf dich
warte ja du bist schon wieder
runtergefallen
kack
hallo kannst gar nich de t-irt sieht ein
bisschen aus wie das von Superman du
musst hier drüber springen SP sehe ich
schon und Blums ich glaube bei dieser
Map klappt sogar alles weil ich diesmal
den Server
hoste climbing Laders try it ach so ja
wahrscheinlich wenn man dann da dran
hängt erstmal sneaken so okay ich bin
jetzt hier oben drauf was jetzt ach ja
hier ach verdammt okay ich bin okay ich
bin richtig sag mir wenn du es geschafft
hast egal ich sehe dich ja dann kommen
wie
süß so Checkpoint mal wieder Stage 1 bis
6 you can stand on top of leaders ja
okay Hoop ach ja cool das geht jetzt
alles wieder ach verdammt
don't read signs if you stand here du
musst die
lesen ich kann nicht lesen weg wenn du
von Leiter zu Leiter springst drück den
Jump und den vorw Buton zur gleichen
Zeit aber press den Jump key nur einmal
und halte den forward key okay also ich
habe es auch anders geschafft spring
einfach
rüber so das ist e wie wie so ein Block
jetzt hierüber die nächste Leiter se
warte hier hier hier ist die ach so dann
musst Du kurz Abstand halten damit ich
up D hinspringen kann ja ich bin schon
im nächsten Wasserbecken habe schon
nächsten Check ah sehr schön so und
jetzt hier rüber da ist eine Kuh drin
war mal h oh mein Gott eine Kuh oh nein
sie wird uns auffressen ja wrong way
sagt er mir falscher Weg au ach so
boah die Schnauze Kuh so Moment warte so
hier ist doch nein Quatsch hä wie hast
denn du wie warst wie hä t s du mal hier
ne oh es regnet ich mach toggle down
falloll also dass der Regen
aufhört Spark Style nenne ich sowas ich
frag mich gerade wirklich wie du
nein guck mal wenn du da auf dem Hoch
bist warte noch mal hoch
nächster näch da
und ist rechts nee andersrum da guck
hier da wo da da hinten drauf da drauf
dein PC rastet aus SP echt wieso hört
man h a ja ja das ist das ist der Lüfter
der ich hoffe mal da kommt bald neuer PC
ne ja ja ja das hört sich an Helikopter
gerade pass mal auf du musst einfach
viel reden dann übertönen wir das
einfach ja ja ich ich ich ma ganz
einfach vololgendes ich starte einfach
PC nochmer neu bevor ich aufnehme weil
das ist die Katastrophe bei ihr ja ich
weiß ich beschw mich zu oft ich weiß ich
weiß aber berechtigt du hast einfach ein
scheiß PC und ich ich ich versuche nur
ich versuche nur mich zu entschuldigen
dass ich darüber bereits informiert bin
ja ach so ja okay ich möchte damit nicht
provozieren ich möchte damit sagen dass
es mir leid tut ich möchte mit meiner
Aussage einfach nur sagen dass ich die
ganze schultld aufs SPK AUA die ganze
Schuld aufs SPK schiebe und ich nicht
Rauch rauche Rauchen tue ich auch nicht
aber Rausche oh mann schon wieder
runtergefallen so wo bleibst ach da da
ich komme schon ich komm schon ich hab's
die ganze Zeit bisher geschafft oh ich
habe wieder zugemacht verdammt
oh wann verdammt da hinten komme ich nie
weiter ja genau da das meinte ich ach so
ach da hab wir was gemeinsam wir Fehlen
der gleichen Stelle so guck jetzt Bo ich
bin drauf ich nicht nein nein nein nein
neinch verdammt ich hätte W gedrückt
halten müssen ach scheiße nee verdammt
so immer genau gleich kommen wir hier so
so jetzt bin ich hier
drauf nein schon wieder ach schade das
jetzt ein bisschen
Herter obwohl es immer noch Beginner ist
wenn wir das hier durch haben haben wir
das erste von von 14 also ihr müsst uns
jetzt einfach in die Kommentare
schreiben was ihr
denkt bzw wie lange wir das machen
sollen weil ich weiß nicht ob wir
komplett alle wie viel waren das 14 kann
hinhauen alle 14 machen sollen weil das
ist gerade die erste Stage und ich denke
das werden locker 20 Parts werden ich
weiß nicht wie viel war perpetur oh mein
Gott ich bin hier drauf luur war 24
glaube ich ich komme nicht weiter ich
lauf dann auf die Leiter drauf nach
unten gehe gell nein ach verdammt da war
noch eine Leiter ach Kacke ich habe beim
letzten Jump
gefilt du musst Doppel sprinten also
nicht Doppel sprinten sondern einfach
nur
sprinten und H
H
eben gerade ohne sprinten da hoch
gekommen cool Spark
Dennis voll selten
Dennis
verdammt verdammt sch eigentlich deinen
richtigen Namen was noch die Youtuber
dass du Dennis heißt ja ja klar steht
aufem Kanal stand aber mal lange Zeit
nicht ne Bo jetzt verkack sort be zweit
spron ewig auf meem Kanal ja
ja
hallo Mann ich verkacke jetzt immer
schon beim zweiten Jump so erster Jump
boah
geschafft jetzt schaffe ich das jetzt
schaffe ich das AH kurz vor Schluss ich
war beim
letzten geschafft geschafft wow nein sag
du versuchst noch zweimal und danach
porte ich
dich
okay oh oh oh verdammt ich habe den
kaputt gemacht na egal mal dahin
so ah knapp willst du hochkmen
ja
Moment ach ach so ich wollte gerade den
Stein okay okay so Checkpoint erstmal
holen und dann jetzt hier drüber best
possibility time 13 Sekunden ja man was
denkt denn von uns Unterhalter und keine
keine skiller die das so
können ich gerade schon sehr gut bei der
Sache bin na ja das Problem ist ich
stehe auf einer Leiter drauf dann gehe
ich Stück zur Seite und dann laufe ich
da irgendwie runter
wieder bin fertig ach J Gangster boah
aber ich finde das macht Spaß mit den
Leitern so dass man da jetzt übrigens
auch so dran stehen kann das finde ich
auf jeden Fall geil dass diese komplette
Map bisher funktioniert ja ja we die
andere Map no nicht so ganz funktioniert
immer ja und da man dann auch schon ein
bisschen verzweifeln hat sich davon
beeinflussen lassen schaffst du das
congratulation Challenge 1 W ginglich
schnell eigentlich noch ja in einem Part
ich würde sagen Aufnahmestopp 14 Minuten
50 jetzt genau passend warte noch die
Kiste congratulation Challenge
try challenges please try normal
challenges
next was hast du genommen da ein Diamant
okay cool also jetzt sind wir fertig so
sind wir fertig wür ich sagen zwei
gibt's dann bei mir falls ich die Kiste
zum laufen kriege und sich das Ganze
nicht an Helikopter der gerade am
abstützen ist bis gleich oder den N